ALI AFSHAR: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name's Ali, and today I'm
going to be talking to you
about revisions in the Google
Drive API and revisions, in
general, in Google Drive.
So firstly, what
is a revision?
Well, every time you change a
file in Google Drive, it is
snapshotted, and the previous
files are saved.
So this way, you have a very
good Undo history that goes
back for a long, long
period of time.
This is not an alien concept to
you if you're a developer.
This is exactly how version
control systems work.
And if you used CVS back in the
day and Subversion since
then, and much more recently
Git and Mercurial and these
nicer tools like this, Google
Drive has this built in, OK?
So anything you can do in Google
Drive, you can also do
with a Google Drive API.
And that's why we have full
revision management there.
So when you upload a file, if
it's been updated or if you
just modified some of the
metadata, you can pass the
flag to make sure that a new
revision is created.
Or you can say, no, I don't want
a new revision created,
and the last revision remains
as the current one.
So really, really useful.
It means you won't lose
your history.
Now, along with the revisions
come a few
extra little features.
So each revision is saved
against a file.
So you can say, give me all the
revisions for this file.
Now, each of those revisions
also can be downloaded.
You can view the metadata.
You can export them if
they're a Google Doc.
So each of these revisions
behaves almost like a file
resource does in the API.
So when normally you would get
a file or export a file or
download a file, with a
revision, you can do them for
each of the revisions of that
file, so that's really, really
useful and essentially a
version control system.
So that's the first part--
downloading and grabbing
metadata from
the individual revisions.
Another part of this is
publishing revisions.
Now, we have a feature where you
can actually say, I want
this revision of a file to be
published to the world, OK?
Now, you do that by setting the
published property, and
obviously that's a Boolean.
You set it to "publish
true/false." If a revision has
been published, then a new field
appears there, and that
is the published link field.
And that gives you a link to a
URL, which you can give that
to people to publish.
So you can say, I want to
publish, say, revision number
three of a file.
Now, when you create revision
number four, four will not be
automatically published unless
you publish it or unless you
set a flag called "publish
auto," which means publish the
most recent revision,
whatever it is.
That's really useful, because if
you think about the normal
workflow of creating content
to go online or within your
company intranet or whatever,
usually you want to create the
latest revision, have a round
of reviews, maybe go over it
yourself, maybe think about it
for a while, and then publish.
So the publish step usually
comes after the content
creation step.
So that would be a
workflow here.
And again, the API is
there to help you.
Create the file, publish one
revision, modify it.
When you're happy with
it, publish the next
revision, and so on.
So essentially, that is all
there is to revisions.
Just to recap, a revision is
kind of like a file, but each
time you save a file, each time
you modify file, a new
revision is created.
These are stored, and you can
grab them one by one and
download their content or look
at their title, whatever you
want to do.
Additionally, we have publishing
functionality.
So you can publish a revision,
you can automatically publish
the latest revision, and
you can keep revisions
unpublished.
So thanks very much.
That was a very short
introduction.
There's not much to it there.
If you need the feature,
you will use it.
Just to go on, there is also--
yep, a question on YouTube.
This is a great one-- "turning
Google Drive into Subversion.
I guess I do care." So I guess
they're saying, can I turn a
Subversion history into a
Google Drive history?
Yeah, you can, actually.
Why not?
And vice versa.
So to go from Google Drive to
Subversion, what you would do
is you would find the file you
want or find all the files you
want, but you'd have
to individually
on a per-file basis.
That's really the
difference here.
Subversion is a repository-based
thing.
Google Drive is a file-based
So you would get the file.
You would download the first
revision, copy it into your
Subversion repository, and
commit it there, download the
next revision, commit it there,
and you would build the
mapping like that.
And you could store the
revision idea against
Subversion's revision ID.
And you could store them
somewhere in the database or
something, or a file.
And that would work for you.
To go in the opposite direction,
you would check out
a specific Subversion
revision.
I can't even remember
how to do that.
It's been a long time since, but
it's probably like minus R
and then the revision number.
Then you would check that
out into a local file.
Then you would upload that file
if it's the first one.
Subsequent checkouts, you would
then update the file,
causing a new revision
to be created.
And again, while you're
doing it, I would
probably save the metadata.
So yes, it's not quite the
same as Subversion.
You wouldn't really use it to
manage source code because of
the non-repository
style nature.
But it's very similar
functionality, and you could
easily create a mapping between
the two of them.
So that's Subversion.
These days, people don't really
use that too much.
So thanks very much
for watching.
If you have any questions,
please ask them on Stack
Overflow, or get in
touch on Google+.
Thank you very much.
Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]